I think for a lot of people the word
robot conjures up a humanoid robot I
think that's a little bit different
thing I try to disavow people with that
because human body why does nothing
doesn't why yeah we're not we're not
some model of anything right just do
better a better job and different
because when when machines do things
that humans can't do that's when we can
do things together that are right
doesn't do just what you think so but
artificial intelligence as you know very
well I think people are very aware now
it's having this resurgence in this this
new wave of artificial intelligence with
machine learning and at its core now
this idea that machines can take you
know look at a million images and start
figuring out how to label them and do it
better than humans because of how
they've been trained once they beat us
at chess and then at jeopardy you know
we should just give right and go well I
might give up in most things there are a
lot of things that they are nowhere
close to so I said there's nothing left
we're done let's just move to Mars and
I'm looking at my photo sorter on my
computer and you give it face
recognition some hints and give it a few
photos to train on one of these photos
found me when I was 11 was 11 I bet I'm
I resemble myself of course but still
that's pretty amazing it says we think
this is you please confirm like yeah
it's me
is a fuzzy photo taken on a Kodak
Instamatic yeah so that's what this
learning era AI is really all about it's
in everything that we are doing so hot
you're an AI robot assist what is that
well generated robotics is this merger
of AI and the physical world the the
mechanics the embodiment of a machine
and so you need to sort of understand
both the mechanics and the AI to make a
physical smart so so what do you create
in your lab we try asking that from
anybody's got a lab what would create
what's happening in your lab what's
happening so we're trying
to to look at sort of next-generation
robotics we're trying to look at what I
know how can we take this from program
machines the machines that can learn
that can learn fast they can learn
things that that we haven't taught them
and you know do things that we normally
don't think robots can do like
self-replicate be creative things like
that they have self-awareness
you know that's self-awareness is one of
these these Holy Grails that would say
of robotics is going to take a while but
they were on that path
[Music]
you